- I have something funny though.
So, when you told your mom who
loves to cook soulful food,
like soul food.
- [Common] Yeah.
- That you were gonna be a vegan,
how'd that go over?
Was she like, "Wait, what?"
- Well, first of all,
she was like, "What
are you talking about?"
Like, when I didn't want to
eat the turkey at Thanksgiving.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the foods that I normally ate,
they were in shock.
She was kind of like, she
felt like I rejected her
and I understand
'cause that was her way
of giving love, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Her son is coming home, I'm
working all over the time.
- And she spent a minute on that turkey.
- She spent a minute on that.
She cooked the greens.
But once she saw I was for
real about it, you know,
the next year, the next year,
then it was like, okay,
I gotta start cooking some
vegetarian food for this guy.
And she did it
and it wasn't that good
at first, you know?
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
That's like me trying to bake
with all the like healthy sugars.
I'm like.
- Yeah, you gotta learn how to.
- Yeah.
- You gotta learn how to still--
- The chemistry of that, yeah.
- Now, let me say, because
I know my mother's watching,
she has improved.
(audience laughs)
She's a very good.
- Your mama is gonna whoop your ass.
(Common laughs)
- She's a very good.
- She's like, "I have improved, okay."
- She's good, she's really good now.
- Do you cook?
Do you like cooking?
- No, I don't cook at all.
- I know.
I don't think
you could be judging other
people's skills then.
- Still I know what tastes good,
you know what I'm saying?
- I'm like, look, I was like,
"You know what this tastes like,
"I didn't cook it, so
I'll put it in my mouth."
- Are you a good chef?
- No.
(audience laughs)
No.